[Music]
we have 2013 Hyundai Santa Fe customer
lost his keys we're gonna go and create
turn your keys for the car the cars you
can see is a push to start we're gonna
use the al-ayam 508 already connected to
the internet so let's see how it works
Hyundai
manual selection America
Thunder 30ma No
all right Santa Fairy 1319 this is a
smart key let's try and really mobilize
their this function support model with a
teacher please ensure okay check your
network how's our design mama not
supported by 47 all right we got a
password eight eight one one forty two
now we're gonna go to keyless system a
mobile as a remote control learning
smart key programming perform this
function require all keys to be
relearned yes turn the ignition off it
is off we already have the pinko that I
am keep the pin code press ok confirm
the pin code okay well we're gonna press
ok
and program success now let's do the
other one
you know first yes you're gonna press
okay
then I press like that second one on a
push to start and porygon success we
have two keys in the vehicle right now
from the system I'm gonna disconnect the
OBD and that's the remote one